foreign
[Music]
lovers here's what we're gonna do today
in today's video we'll have a minor
version of the decade in recap videos
that I did a year or two ago however our
scope is going to be for the past three
years and I'll be going through the
notable shows of each season and what I
think is the best new anime
recommendation for the primary audience
of the channel so in this case I'm
talking about the action loving kind of
watches but I'll be giving other genres
some love too so please do watch out for
those and I'll obviously be excluding
sequels for this one I know you're
excited for the video but I'm also
excited to talk to you about today's
sponsor snow break containment Zone snow
break containment zone is a 3D RPG
shooter that's a must-have for any anime
fan who's into these kind of games it
features some awesome gameplay and gives
you the best of what anime fans just
can't get enough of you've got the
Sci-Fi setting the attractive character
designs and gameplay that integrates RPG
elements like character skills along
with the usual frantic pacing of a
shooting game with gameplay that reminds
me a lot of my favorite shooter and
bullet hell games both in my youth in
the recent years I just can't stop being
excited for snow break containment Zone
it does help that it also has a lot of
strategy behind it with so many options
for team composition and weapon upgrades
that you'll have to master in order to
go through the toughest encounters that
the game has to offer another cool thing
is that this game supports
cross-platform play and that'll allow me
to spend a lot of Fun hours on end with
my friends who usually play on a PC the
story is also great and touches on some
of my favorite plot elements like the
clash between science and humanity and
it can be enjoyed in various ways thanks
to the many voice-over options available
I'm talking three languages here English
Japanese and Mandarin pre-registrations
open so you might want to check out the
link in my description and start your
journey with some Nifty rewards like
in-game currency exclusive skins and
weapons the official launch day is July
the 20th but the closed beta starts on
June the 1st so you might want to give
that a shot and get ahead of the pack in
2020 we opened with the winter season
winter 2022 felt really special to me do
you remember how you felt back then
being blissfully unaware of how the
world would change in just a couple of
months there we were happily watching
anime and enjoying the many things that
the jam-packed anime season had to offer
the First shows that jumped out at me
that I quickly watched and grew fond of
were two game shows technically speaking
bovori was a standout show in terms of
plain fun entertainment it's a chill
show that doesn't take itself seriously
and with a cast of lovable characters
and its overall atmosphere lending well
to the overpowered newcomer shtick it
was a winner to me the second one was
Darwin's game I've had an appetite for
death game shows and it just hit a lot
of the right notes for me I wouldn't
call it an anime of the Season not in a
long shot but if you want an ensemble
show that's a tad edgy and fast-paced
then this one could be your calling and
let's not forget Ed invaded if you up
for something in the veins of
psychopaths something a little bit heavy
but filled with action and thrills then
this is a show that you'd want to try
out however my top recommendation would
be Doro hidoro
sleeper here a dark action title that
ended up being a lot better than I
expected it to be I was already hyped to
follow kaiman's adventures in the
dredges of Hull but given the overall
style of the manga with its violence
crass and dark humor I didn't expect
such a good adaptation it's the show for
you if you want something actiony that
doesn't hold back with the mature
content I also dare say success also
held ready the carpet for similar shows
like chainsaw man
foreign
[Music]
struck no one and I mean no one for saw
that we'd be spending the rest of 2020
stuck in our homes and neither did the
anime industry we got suspensions and
delays everywhere and spring 2020 was a
season that was completely ravaged if I
was to look at the bright side of that
however it was the fact that the insane
number of delays allowed dark horses to
ride up and make their Mark something
that they might not have been able to do
had they had to contend with the
Blockbusters of the Season Chief amongst
those then glip near this weird looking
show ended up filling the role of that
season's main edgy action title grabbing
the hearts of fans with this unique
setup and premise before dazzling
everyone with some amazing fight
animation it felt like an Underdog Story
of an anime and when the season was over
it became one of the more memorable
titles of spring 2020 I'd also like to
give some love to two wholesome titles
before its second season princess
connect redive wouldn't have reached the
impressive Heights that I always praised
it for still the first season is a good
chill show that feels like a wholesome
take on gonosuba complete with the same
animation techniques and character
emotes there's also kakushi goto which
has a premise that could evoke memories
of Ira manga Sensei however at the core
of it is a very warm and cozy title more
reminiscent of usagi drop if anything
one hype title did survive the onslaught
of the delays though and it's my pick
for the recommendation of the Season
Tower of God brought to life one of the
most popular Korean webtoons out there
and its transition to anime form ended
up being good it's not exactly a perfect
show not by a long shot and it ended
before we could get to the more exciting
Parts however from the few episodes that
it gave us we can already see the
potential that it has if you're fond of
adventure shows with great world
building then this one's for you
summer 2020 was a wild season we finally
got the much awaited climaxes of snafu
as well as the intended one for Sao if
we're going with the web novel context
re-zero also made its return to much
fanfare and so did the fire force to a
bit lesser Fanfare we also saw what the
bottom of the abyss looked like in GBA I
mean seriously what was up with that
it's an absolute joke and I was really
excited for it too you know oh and
summer also saw the debut of the ever
polarizing rent a girlfriend hot take
but I feel it's over hated not an
amazing show in my opinion but it also
doesn't deserve to be treated like a
punching bag like a lot of people are
doing to it I mean at the end of the day
it's a junk food show that has some
merits like the very attractive designs
they're pretty much are a major reason
people continue to watch and buy the
merchandise of the show and if you
missed the good old days of transfer
student entering magic school and
immediately flexes his power before
gaining a harem Misfit of Demon King
Academy is here for you only this time
everything gets turned up to 100 and it
took the parody approach akin to one
punch man it makes a good compliment to
God of high school the next in line for
the popular webtoon turned anime thing
they did I still think the Tower of God
is better and it's overall the most
complete show for God of high school the
fights are great but it's pacing a
little bit all over the place my pick
for this season then is none of those
instead I looked something more Western
in aesthetic I'm talking about great
Pretender
[Music]
watching it was a thrilling adventure
that always had me on the edge of my sea
wanting more it's artistic in the truest
sense of the word especially for anime
standards and its unique atmosphere did
catch a lot of people's attentions back
then it's perfect if you want something
new and to have some distance away from
the typical anime get up of schools
teenagers and Supernatural powers
foreign
2020 let's just cut to the chase shall
we whether it's the perspective of
Shonen fans or not it's undeniable that
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen actually dominated this
season the show burst into the ceiling
while not having the same impact as say
Demon Slayer in 2019 I'd say that Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen even had that show beat in
some categories I mean ultimately Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen is an exciting Shonen that
everyone should at least give a shot and
it combines interesting Powers
unpredictable character Dynamics and
insane fight animation three things the
action anime fans absolutely love but
let's not forget to give some love to
the other stars of the season for people
who love sweet romantic shows there's
Tony Kaku Kawaii akodama drive also
managed to carve its Legacy Midway
through its run being this season's
western-like Sci-Fi show and in a
similar vein but in a less Full Throttle
fighting sense but more of a
philosophical moralistic perspective we
have Moriarty the Patriot and how can we
forget wandering witch an enjoyable
fantastic Adventure well it's not as
popular by any stretch I also found
myself liking kimisen and I was more
than happy to know that it's getting a
second season which was a complete
surprise considering how Niche the show
was
foreign
and that wraps up 2020 well we ended the
year on an uncertain note as far as the
world and the industry went there was so
much more to be excited for in 2021 for
one the biggest sequels awaited the
year's very doorstep as we opened the
year with aot's final season yeah back
then we all thought it was going to be
one grand finale before they started
chopping the broadcast repeatedly but it
became a joke and there was the much
awaited sequel to promise Neverland
something that in hindsight is better
left very deep in the annals of history
as nothing but a point of footnote
winter 2021 did introduce the world to
my pick musoku tensei musoku tensei in
anime form is a true Testament to how
great an anime can be if he gets the
love and care of the anime production
team backing it up one of the best
adaptations in recent memory it's also
one of the most influential ones in the
novel side of things you can clearly see
how it became a Pioneer to one of the
most popular and notorious genres out
there and when it comes to the aspect of
character growth and World building it's
hard to find an it's a guy anime that's
a match from ushoku tensei personally
I'd also like to give a shout out to
skate Infinity from this season one of
the notable Sports shows of the year
being someone who enjoyed self-help
rom-coms tomozaki was another show that
completely caught my eye I got what I
bargained for in that show with a brand
of Comedy that really clicked with me
speaking of domozaki horimiya also aired
this season and it ended up being one of
my favorite romance shows out there
[Music]
foreign
comes spring and spring ended up being
really stacked in terms of new anime
right off the bat we have the fan
favorite Tokyo Revengers making their
debut time travel gritty fights no
shortage of drama and a lot of
attractive characters no wonder Tokyo
Avengers became one of the most popular
news shows out there and this is evident
if you look at the merchandise being
produced and sold in anime stores
especially in Japan VV also aired in
this season and he got my pick for
original anime of the season it's a show
filled with intense action and it has
quite a social commentary and great
music to boot speaking of those elements
there's also 86 the Mecca and sci-fi
genre just seems to have a knack for
delving into social commentary as the
two mentioned titles 86 for me is also a
show that is notably strong in terms of
character Dynamics flanked by the
musical Genius of hiroyuki Samano this
sure gets a nomination for anime of the
season but ultimately my pick is odd
taxi
a strange pick if you just look at the
cover art and the overall feel of the
show true it may not be as thematically
deep as the two side fi titles and it
may not get your adrenaline pumping the
way Tokyo Avengers does however I think
that in a vacuum our taxi is a stroke of
Genius it tells its story in a unique
way having many plot points intertwined
and left for the audience to follow it
is a brilliant show that may have
Skeptics looking at it twice and it may
not be for everyone but I heartily
recommend it for those wanting an
experience you'd never thought you'd
find in an anime before we leave spring
2021 behind I'd like to give a shout out
to Higa hero a show that ended up being
one I really loved mainly due to the
character development yoshida's
relationship with saiyu in the show is
something else and it's a show that made
me want to root for both of them and one
I won't be recommending awesomeake I
would say that it's a guilty pleasure
show for me mainly for the voice actor
cast that featured my favorites and its
cute character designs
[Music]
so in comparison summer 2021 felt more
muted there's not a lot of Blockbusters
coming and while I enjoyed detective is
already dead the show is admittedly
flawed in a lot of ways one of the most
anticipated titles from the season ended
up having a lukewarm reception by the
end and it's easy to see why I'm at
least glad season 2 has been announced
but understandably not a lot share my
enthusiasm realist hero remake our life
and spirit Chronicles are also titles
that I liked however none of these three
really set the world on fire and they're
nowhere near anime of the season for me
too vanitas has a better shot at taking
home the crown being a spiritual
successor to Pandora Hearts and having a
setup that evokes feelings of Boom go
stray dogs or Black Butler it's the show
that female fans absolutely adored and
it boasts awesome music and great
characterization the latter which is a
trademark of series Creator Jean
mojizuki if you were to ask me of my
vote for this season however I'll take
you to the world of Chinese animation
and give a vote for link click many
considered it a sleeper hit of the
season and I am inclined to agree it's
an interesting story of time travel
backed with breathtaking art filled with
a signature they're in style true for
people who watch things like Steins Gate
link clicks plot is not exactly
Innovative or unique however for those
who are up for a Sci-Fi time travel
story and want something new and with
different vibes from the typical anime
then link click is my recommendation
full 2021's Crown is for ranking of
Kings to lose while many people
overlooked it because of the childish
art style ranking of Kings easily became
everyone's favorite as early as halfway
through the season an Underdog Story
done right it's an anime that contains a
lot of strong themes of moral lessons
it's not every day that you see a show
look so simple yet contains some of the
best character writing and memorable
moments that cut deep if you're looking
for an Underdog Story of any sort then
you can't go without at least trying
rankings of Kings on the action side of
things though I'd love to give shout
outs to both Aristocrat assassin and
tact-off both ended up being a lot
better than I expected given the stigma
that people have for their respective
genres isakai and mobile game
promotional anime blue period also made
its debut this season for the most
artistic fans who need a stroke of
inspiration lastly how could we forget
gomi one of the most popular School
comedies finally got as much awaited
anime adaptation and I tell you what it
didn't disappoint on a slightly similar
note we also got the meruco anime which
I also liked a lot despite the
surprisingly heavy amount of anime fan
service for the supposed nature of the
show we're just halfway through but if
you like what you've been seeing so far
why don't you hit that like button up
there and with that done let's continue
as we've got a lot more anime to talk
about
foreign
two episodes two episodes is all it took
for my dress-up darling to steal
everyone's hearts in the winter 2022
season including mine that's why I'm
putting it as my top pick for winter
2022. in a season full of Blockbuster
sequels my dress-up darling ended up
being a standout show that pretty much
has everything you want from a rom-com
an attractive main character a lot of
fluffy and cute moments in between the
fan service and most importantly Great
Character chemistry when people
criticize power fantasy Issa guys for
being Wishful film and Anime post 2022
me could scoff because this show is the
definition of wish fulfillment in my
opinion I don't mean that in a negative
light but it is undeniable that a lot of
my anime fans especially the socially
awkward lot would love a [__] in their
lives charismatic upbeat attractive and
always supportive we just can't get
enough of her can we this season doesn't
have a lot of big popular new anime
unfortunately this rkb sailor uniform if
you want another flavor of cute and
lighthearted for me this show is most
notable for how pretty it looks the
attention to animation and just how
sparkly everything looks is something
you gotta see to believe rust eater
bisco though is this season's offering
for the more action-adventure orientated
viewers there's also love of kill to
provide something for the same kinds of
fans who wants something less
Fantastical and more mature more
grounded in human drama and heavier
themes I was so excited for Requiem of
the Rose King but it's one of the titles
that you're better off reading manga for
go read the [__] manga
[Music]
spring 2022 followed and with it came
the much awaited anime adaptation of spy
family spy family is a true pleasure to
watch the hype is very much Justified
with it just hitting the right nose
everywhere and being a show that I can
easily turn on to unwind with after a
busy day at work it's got a lovable cast
a lot of entertaining moments and very
wholesome Dynamics my personal nitpick
however is that there's nothing forcing
me to watch the episodes one after
another it's a show that I do enjoy
watching no doubt there's nothing to
convince me to keep flipping to the next
episode if you catch my drift sure it
comes with a genre but it's to the very
minor yet relevant nitpick that holds
the show back ever so slightly for me on
the contrary my pick for this season
summertime render gave me all the
reasons to keep watching until I found
myself binging half of it in one go it's
a show that has everything you'd ask for
from something in this genre mystery
action more twists and turns to keep the
plot going just when you thought the
good guys had won think something like
re-zero but with way higher stakes and
tension thanks to his genius twist to
shinpei's time loot Powers 25 episode is
all it takes to satisfyingly wrap up
what I would consider anime of the Year
following the success of my dress up
darling we have Shiki Mori I like the
show I mean I really do but it just
doesn't capture the magic of its
supposed predecessor still you can give
it a try if you like the genre enough
the same can be said of couple of
cuckoos which I liked as well before
leaving this season behind we can't
ignore the sleeper hit of the season
your boy Kong Ming came in with little
Fanfare but it ended up being one of the
most popular anime of this season
there's just something with the main
characters that makes you want to root
for them so much Aiko's Dynamic is
something I'm sure a lot of us can
relate to and following her on her road
to success is inspirational if anything
summer 2022's lineup didn't feel as
stacked you got much awaited sequels for
classroom of the elite made in abyss and
devil is a part-timer and are not as
anticipated one for rent a girlfriend
looking at it from the original anime
side of things nothing truly stood out
entering the season however once the
dust settled I say the season did well
enough for itself call of the night I'd
say was the most hyped one entering the
season for all its worth it was one of
the best new anime of the Season
featuring breathtaking art and great
overall direction although the
characters could indeed be hit or miss
Uncle from another world is also a
noteworthy show it's really funny with
its meta humor but it also had a
troubled production that doesn't matter
now but imagine how us fans felt a year
ago when the next episode just wouldn't
come out a show that came out of nowhere
however was licorice recoil while people
didn't think of it much before airing it
ended up being everyone's favorite this
season this is largely due to the simple
yet thematically strong plot the
extremely entertaining characters and
how it Blends the light-hearted moments
with genuinely emotional moments it's a
show that makes you come comfortable
with and care so much about the
characters and that's something you
don't get to see often and I won't
pretend that gojima's praise for the
show didn't at least give some extra
push to make still skeptical fans tune
in licorice recoil may as well be my
pick for the season but I give the
slight edge to cyberpunk edge Runners
I've lauded modern video game
adaptations and Edge one is probably as
the best example of it from the art to
the action that keeps you wanting more
it's my recommendation this is
especially for people who aren't yet to
attuned with the overall anime aesthetic
or style to enjoy licorice recoil as
much trigger does it again that's not
surprising honestly speaking is it as a
final footnote though I'll shout out the
other shows that I like from this season
my stepmom's daughter is my ex as well
as engage kiss nothing too special but
never less enjoyable for me
we close out 2022 with the fall season
and what a season this was make no
mistake chainsaw man was by far one of
the most anticipated shows entering a
season said anticipation was so strong
that around this time you just couldn't
avoid seeing people hyping up chainsaw
man to be one of the best action anime
out there if you're looking from a fight
hype and animation perspective the show
didn't disappoint it's my recommendation
for you action-loving fans for those who
love exciting battles and hinged
violence and eye-popping animation then
this is definitely the one for you
however an easy path to Domination by
chainsaw man was stopped by Bocce the
rock of all shows it was Underdog show
that took the anime World by storm
thanks to its relatable characters and
it being a cute girl show that places a
lot of importance on the music aspects
and character growth a good balance of
serious and light-hearted moments as
well as very great pacing make Bocce the
Sleep hit of the season and a very
strong anime of the Season candidate for
me I found it funny that chainsaw man
found an unlikely rival in this Plucky
show that comes from a genre that's way
different let's not forget the other
hits of the Season though there's blue
lock which gives us a new and less
idealistic approach to the sports genre
then there's Eminence in Shadow meme
energy Supreme the show is just the
right amount of craziness you'd expect
from an overpowered protagonist title
that works as a parody of the genre
which from Mercury gives us a
much-needed Breath of Life to the Gundam
franchise and I had fun with Akiba made
War as well as reincarnated as a sword
finally we reach 2023 the start of 2023
has been um okay I haven't seen any new
anime that set the world on fire yet but
it's got some nice shows to keep the
positive momentum from 2022 going Angel
spoils me rotten is this season's sweet
and Charming show for those watching
that kind of series on a somewhat
similar note we have domojan is a girl
and Kubo won't let me be invisible for
more entertaining rom-coms and while
they're nowhere near popular enough to
be considered notable shows I have my
share of personal guilty pleasures from
this season including ice blade sorcerer
high card reborn to master the blade and
spy classroom if I were to pick an anime
recommendation from the season I would
have gone for near it's good but it's
cursed by a terrible production
circumstances therefore I'm going to
give the title this season to Trigun
Stampede yes I know it's not exactly the
Trigun 90s fans loved they found
different in all sorts of ways despite
practically telling the same story it
does look different and all and the
approach is to make a much more
character-driven story as opposed to the
plot-driven 90s story Trigun Stampede
didn't exactly take the anime World by
storm but considering that the average
National version was a cult classic
albeit a very notable one the current
version's reception is just on par with
expectations for someone looking for
something to try however I eagerly
recommend giving this one a shot
you know it's been a pleasure going
through the past few years and talking
about some of my favorite anime since
then so how did you find my past three
years in recap any other shows that
you'd love to recommend I'm waiting if
you enjoyed the list you can go ahead
and check out some of my previous videos
that way you can join me in taking a
trip down memory lane or laughing at
past me for being excited in the
pre-season videos for shows that ended
up under achieving either way I'm glad
to have you guys here and I truly
appreciate the support thank you for
watching and staying and I appreciate
those likes and subscriptions too hope
to see you again next time